leopard two tanks the heavy weapons
which for weeks were at the center of a
war of words today finally given the
green light by Germany and historic but
uneasy step for a country which before
this war had a long-standing practice of
not sending lethal weapons to conflict
zones
foreign
yourself
the Tank's debate has been
internationally and domestically
divisive some have taken to the streets
to try to force the government to act
but others haunted by history are
terrified of being drawn into a wider
War this has been a difficult decision
for Germany while the majority of the
public want to support Ukraine some fear
by sending heavy weapons they could
become the next Target and after all
this is a huge step it's the first time
German tanks have been sent to a
European Battlefield since World War II
seven decades on the memory of that
conflict still casts Long Shadows over
Berlin what do you think about Germany
allowing leopard two tanks to go to
Ukraine
so I think it's a very tough situation
but
I think also doing nothing wouldn't be
right so I think it's the right decision
to help Ukraine Germany is getting too
involved into the war and
um yeah I don't want my son to be a
soldier in the war it's a crazy idea
because Germany is now part of the war
and it's going to get a very big problem
for the whole world maybe nuclear bombs
politicians are by no means death to
these concerns but with today's
announcement the German government has
gone further than many would have
imagined 12 months ago it is a
significant with regard to the political
domain so Germany at the end of the day
has has moved itself or has been moved
by all its allies carried over the over
the red lines that Germany has given
itself for such a long time
sending these tanks may not be the last
Red Line Germany has to cross the war is
evolving presenting fresh political and
moral challenges for all involved
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Berlin